Well,
thank you very much everybody for coming.
It's a tremendous honor
to be here at Google.
I'm really in awe of the speakers
who have proceeded me on this podium.
There's so many writers and thinkers
and men and women of action who has been
part of the Google talk series.
Most of them have presented some very
specific area of knowledge or even wisdom
or they've talked about how
to do something in particular.
Um,
as a writer,
what I have to offer is story
and language and that's it.
There's not going to be a takeaway
because art is the marriage of content and
form and form cannot be
retold or summarized.
So
I'm going to read to you from my book
for Single Mothers Working as train
conductors,
which some readers and critics have
described as an essay collection.
Some have said it's a book length essay.
Some call it a memoir.
That's my publisher because they say that
essay collection is the marketing kiss
of death. Um, some call
it a story collection,
but it really is an essay collection.
Um,
but whatever you call
it, um, it takes up a,
a grab bag of subjects
that are obsessions for me.
Translation.
Untranslatability I've actually,
I've forged a new path in essay writing.
There are a lot of
essays about translation,
but I am the first writer I know
who writes about not translating.
I realized after this book came out that
it has two essays in it that are about
books that I decided not to
translate and why. And I haven't.
I have another one in mind.
Um,
and I have been told that when
you write from your own life, uh,
you will only ever write one book.
This was something that a writing teacher
thundered at me when I was young and I
was turning in a story that was purported
to be fiction, but clearly it was not.
But I think I found the solution because
if you write about books you have not
translated, you will never
run out of material. Um,
so the obsessions that I take up in this
book, translation on translatability,
uh, Russian, French and Yiddish culture,
literature and language.
I worked with French and Russian at the
UN. I did not work with the addition.
The UN other obsessions include Judaism,
marriage and divorce and chronic illness.
I'm going to tell you this story which
is one section of for single mothers
working as train conductors,
uh,
which is a highly subjective,
even quirky account of my experiences
being hired as a new staff employee at the
United Nations. This piece takes
up some other subjects as well,
but they're all subsumed under the heading
of the resistance and grief that we
human beings display when we're unwilling
and he going through life transitions.
And in this case,
it's the transition from a high flying
international career as it diplomatic and
conference interpreter of Russian and
English to a desk job requiring minimal
knowledge of a few languages.
Before I transitioned into a job as a
translator working with documents in
Russian, French, and
Spanish. Another transition,
it describes as the transition from the
freedom of self employment to being a
tiny cog in an immense bureaucracy.
And both of those transitions were
occasioned by a different transition,
which was the transition from
health to chronic illness.
Now this is a worm's eye view of what
it's like to work at the United Nations
and it's not terribly favorable.
So I'll give you some background, some
context, but before I get to that,
I want to say that there is a kind of
open secret about my book which I'll share
with you.
It's something that authors are always
enjoined not to say about their work,
but I'm a debut author.
I haven't mastered the protocols and the
etiquette so I can say whatever I want
now until my second book comes out,
which I don't think will be anytime soon.
This one took over a decade.
And that open secret is that
my book is autobiographical.
I don't know why this is often associated
with shame for writers and many
writers will do almost,
they will stand on their head to avoid
admitting this even if it's true.
The pedigree of autobiographical
writing is superb. Everything from,
uh, Augustine's confessions,
Lord make me chased,
but not yet to the little house on the
prairie to remembrance of things past,
which you'll hear more about in a moment.
Um, these are some of my favorite books,
but, um, I am,
I cannot hide the fact that
my work is autobiographical.
It's transparently clear. I live on
the upper west side of Manhattan.
My narrator lives on the
upper west side of Manhattan.
I worked as an interpreter
and translator of Russian,
French and Spanish and my narrator worked
as an interpreter and translator of
Russian, French, Spanish.
I have a chronic
degenerative lung disease.
My Meritor has a chronic where
you, you get the idea. Um,
but even though it's won a
prize for literary nonfiction,
this book and my writing in
general embraces subjectivity,
memory lapses,
hearsay and speculation.
And as such, it should not, it cannot
and should not be fact checked.
Its purpose is to tell a story,
not to say, here's what happened.
I would compare it to a
retouched photograph. Um,
so getting back to the United Nations,
I said I wanted to give you some context
because of the unfavorable impression
that my reading may give you.
I believe in the United Nations.
I believe in its mission.
I believe in multilateralism,
but many of my UN coworkers,
and I have a sneaking sympathy for
that famous remark by John Bolton,
who was George W. Bush, uh,
ambassador to the United Nations when he
said that if the top 10 stories of the
United Nations secretary,
it should suddenly disappear
and nobody would miss them.
And our sympathy for this remark
has nothing to do with our politics.
Uh,
you would have to search high and low to
find a staffer at the UN who supported
George W. Bush, let alone Trump. Um,
it has more to do with the way the
organization is run. Sometimes,
um,
the UN is in desperate need of reform.
That reform will probably
never take place. Um,
but it is nonetheless it really necessary
and indispensable organization. Uh,
and one of the problems is that
because its ideals are so lofty,
when it inevitably fails, that
failure seems even greater than it is.
But, um, to get back to the top 10 story,
the stories of the unit of
the secretary of building.
I think one of the reasons my colleagues
and I would not be sorry if it
disappeared is because it houses a moment,
the other things,
the human resources department
and to get hired at the UN,
which in my case took several years,
you have to jump through so many
hoops and go through a ridiculous,
uh, gauntlet to do, prove
your qualifications.
I actually had to come in with a rolling
suitcase that contained all of the
books I had translated so they could
estimate how many words I had translated
during my previous decade
and a half as a translator.
And this kind of thing causes people to
start their work at the UN already with
an enormous chip on their
shoulder toward their employer.
There are some good things that the,
in the top 10 stories of the UN,
there is a restroom that has a stunning
view of midtown Manhattan for women
only.
Um,
although I'm told that it's been used
as a viewing post to look down on the
roofs of lower buildings nearby.
When couples are interesting and they're
unaware that they're visible. Um,
it also has a locked
room on the top floor,
reachable only by a creaky twisting
staircase that contains nothing else but a
ping pong table.
And this is one flight up from
the secretary general's office.
The Ping Pong table room is a place
where diplomats go late at night when
they're locked. A deadlocked,
I should say in talks,
they bang a little ball around to blow
off steam before they go back to the
negotiation table.
One hopes to achieve better results.
Um,
so the UN does everything it can
to reduce international tensions.
And in that connection,
I do think that the United Nations
is important and indispensable.
It's the only place in the world where
all hundred and 93 countries can come
together to discuss everything that needs
to be discussed from a sexual violence
in conflict to food insecurity,
to border control,
counter terrorism,
how to stop female genital mutilation
and the human rights of women,
ethnic and racial minorities,
people with disabilities, uh,
and children.
I don't agree with those people who say
we should turn our backs on the UN and
instead found an institution
that's for democracies only.
I think that would be very,
very problematic.
I think that the non democracies are
precisely the countries that need to be
kept in the loop and in the discussion.
Furthermore,
I'm not sure who would decide
which countries are democracies.
Is the Democratic People's
Republic of Korea? Uh, democracy?
Some people obviously think so.
The Democratic Republic of Congo,
also known as the international
capital of rape. Um,
and then there are countries
whose democratic credentials,
credentials have been burnished for
centuries that seem to be veering toward
other forms of rule.
And there are democracies that become
authoritarian and then one hopes return to
democracy.
Are they going to join this hypothetical
organization than be expelled and then
reapply for admission when
they return to democracy.
So with these unanswered questions,
um,
I will now read to you
Proust at rush hour. Um,
there are two things you need to know
because this is not quite at the beginning
of the book. It references, uh,
the lung disease,
which I was diagnosed with in the course
of working as a contractor at the UN
and undergoing all the processes
for becoming a staffer.
And it also references
my bid for that job,
which was a bid for financial
and professional security.
So Proust at rush hour,
my job is a drag,
like most nine to five gigs I imagine.
But Oh,
the commute,
the commute is a golden border at the
beginning and end of each work day that
sheds some of its shimmer onto
the leaden expanse in between.
I should add that I wrote this a few
months after I became a permanent staffer
and I didn't realize until a few years
later that it was actually a lament for
the last freedom of self
employment. So, but oh, the commute.
The commute is a golden border at the
beginning and end of each work day that
shed some of it's Shimmer shimmer
onto the leaden expanse in between.
I'm a New Yorker,
so taking the subway to work is a given.
The subway provides in miniature all of
the charms of long distance train travel
minus the view.
There is the unencumbered time,
a commodity beyond price for those who
sell their waking hours in order to
afford a place to sleep.
There is the heady state of in between
this a brief release from all worldly
entanglement.
There is the fact that subway travel is
for now at least incompatible with email
and cell phones and that it will always
be incompatible with vacuuming dishes
and laundry.
They are about half a dozen things tops
that you can do on the subway dose.
Observe the people around
you, listen to music, read,
think things we should all do more often.
I was not always a commuter.
I used to be self employed.
I worked from home and when I traveled
by conveyance of choice was the jet
plane. State banquets at
the Kremlin mafia trials,
forgotten literary masterpieces,
KGB files declassified under Yeltsin
to be reclassified later under Putin,
I translated them all.
It was a house in time.
The border between working and not
working was porous. When work was slow,
I took a walk or a yoga class.
When a deadline loomed,
I worked weekends or evenings as to why
people dreaded Monday and thanked God.
It was Friday.
I lacked all understanding when
people spoke of their commutes.
I listened as to an account
of some quaint foreign ritual,
but in my mid thirties panic bore
down by health insurance was patchy.
My retirement meeker,
my income blossomed and
shriveled with the seasons.
I began planning for the transition from
free spirit to commuter boning up on my
French, so it was to get that
job I'd set my sights on.
Apart from the expense,
there was nothing onerous in this.
Who would object to spending some months
in Paris immersed in the language of
Moliere and sitters,
guns or this was a dream I had nurtured
and then set aside almost 20 years
before and I was glad of any
pretext to make it come true.
Last French mastered.
I prepared to take up my new job as an
interpreter of Russian and French into
English.
Working in a tall building of green glass
at midtown Manhattan is eastern edge
and now unforeseen things began
to happen during the trial period.
Before the job was to become permanent.
My newly failing lungs made it difficult
then impossible for me to perform that
demanding work.
A seemingly from job offer went limp
through a series of short contracts within
the organization.
I tumbled down and down in status and job
satisfaction though not salary until I
landed in a permanent position editing
English language documents with duties
that called for no more than a passing
knowledge of French or any other foreign
language movement up the hierarchy I would
come to understand was the reward for
a different sort of fluency all together
directly proportionate to the climbers
ability to say nothing and offend no
one in the most elegant way possible.
All at great length.
Shortly after I started the permanent job,
I was copied on an email from
one higher up to another.
It's contents presumably affecting my
future in some way that embodied the style
so utterly that I would be
remiss if I did not rape,
reproduce it here quote.
While I do not think that your concern
is misplaced, ran this missive,
I would say that it may be premature to
suggest that the guidelines would apply
uniformly as they stand to all staff.
I hope I'm not being
overly sanguine about this,
but I tend to think that just as our
specificities are being taken into account
to a large extent in the interim,
they would readily be accommodated
in the long term. In other words,
the guidelines only state the policy,
which will no doubt allow for some
special dispensation. However,
I do not dispute for a second that
yours is a legitimate concern.
When I got this,
this is just an aside,
I didn't know what I
was going to do with it,
but it seemed like such a fantastic
example of something that I printed it out
to save and then later
I found this use for it,
but I reminded myself as I printed out
the email and taped it to the wall over
my computer.
Between the map of the Economic Community
of West African states and another of
the former Yugoslavia, we you get slot
republic of Macedonia. I was lucky
at last, I had a permanent job.
It came with health insurance,
which saved me thousands each month on
crucial prescriptions, medical equipment,
rentals and doctor visits,
disability benefits.
If I became unable to work a possibility,
I now had to entertain dental coverage,
so dazzling,
but even the receptionist at the
dentist office was impressed. Liberal,
sick leave,
of which I would take full advantage.
A son splashed office with a view of
boats chugging up and down the East River,
access to a post office bank
credit union employee only,
low interest mortgages, medical
service, international news,
Stan yoga dancers size
and [inaudible] classes,
a cappuccino bar,
cafeteria,
fancy restaurant with enormous bowls of
whipped cream and raspberries on the all
you can eat dessert buffet,
nine levels of instruction at
no cost in my choice of Spanish,
Arabic or mandarin and high school
choirs visiting from the heartland,
singing songs of international
peace and brotherhood.
All of this right on the premises.
All mine in exchange for spending my
days doing nothing or what felt like
nothing where what I find
something better indeed.
I often ask myself that question,
although my Russian and my newly acquired
French are as noted superfluids in the
job where I've ended up,
the hiring process mysteriously included
an eight hour language proficiency test
and just as mysteriously
the word translator figures
prominently in my title.
With some luck in a few years I might
transfer back to a post where foreign
languages could prove useful.
In the meantime,
I've decided to read Proust.
Yes, in search of lost time,
also known as remembrance of
things past in the original French,
all of it,
seven volumes on the subway standing up.
Here's the drill. In the morning
I get to the subway platform,
pull out the book and open to the page
where I left off the previous evening.
When the subway doors
glided apart and my stop.
It's a fine addition with
the thinnest of paper,
the title tool than guilt on the spine
and a slender grow grain bookmarks.
So Mina.
Also guilt,
failure to get the volume into position
before train pulls in means I may not
get to do any reading that morning as
it's often too crowded to fumble in my bag
for the book after I board
other things to do before I
pushed my way onto the train,
lay my hands on a pen in my bag and make
sure the sticky note inside the books
back cover has not come
unglued and fallen out.
The pen and the little yellow scrap of
paper are for writing down on familiar
words.
If I don't have a pen at the ready or if
the sticky note is missing are already
filled with scrawls from previous
commutes, I'll go back later,
reread the pages and write down the
unfamiliar words that I didn't capture on
the first pass.
Then I'll look up,
look them up during the slow moments at
the office that add up to a work day and
another and another.
The office with the river view is
a wash in battered foreign language
dictionaries that it would that appear
to have language there for decades.
If it weren't for Proust and my compulsion
to look up every single unfamiliar
word I come across,
they would get very little use indeed.
Here are a few entries from
my Proust word list. Most Sad,
Nino de on Dean,
a Lumbee k may have
early class Gootee gas.
We Gay TAPPC.
Sylvia had tests on filamentous please
still and left Vicky meaning respectively
Sullen simpering water,
sprite convoluted markish carnation
jubilation tea party to warble,
upholsterer villainy procuress
calling card and Greyhound.
I'm on the Seventh Avenue
Express now hurdling downtown.
In one hand I hold the book and in the
other the pen so I cannot properly be
called a strap hanger.
I assume a wide stance.
Bend my knees and ride the
train like a skateboard.
In the 12 minutes or so,
it takes the train to barrel down the
line from 96th street to Times Square.
I fight in notius inertia's pulled
toward free fall into some stranger's lap
plunging instead into the bucolic
village of Comray or the Paris salons and
cafes where representatives of the Hook
Push Yc and the Denny Mon cross paths.
I read Proust almost exclusively
on the subway on weekends.
I rarely pick up the book, the little
volume with the grow green marker lies on,
touched on my desk from Friday evening
time of unseemly rejoicing until Monday
morning time of dread beyond reason.
This runs counter to my notion of myself
as someone with an almost religious
reverence for literature and it's grades,
but there it is.
My life yields up few moments that
are conducive to the concentration and
discipline that Proust requires.
Every week or two I indulge in a
dalliance with some other author.
There's some takes. Sometimes it takes
place on the subway, but mostly off.
When I read on the downlow,
it's always in English.
No need to keep a running lookup list
with the attendant pen and posted note.
Usually the work of some contemporary
author who style is relatively terse.
They'll compare to Preuss,
Proust. Everything seems terse.
I can tear through a contemporary novel
of two to 300 pages in the time it takes
to read 25 to 30 pages of proofs.
Read in brief spurts.
Cruz, 3000 pages. Well,
the 700 I've read so far reveal reveal
themselves to be a series of hundreds and
hundreds of linked discursive essays,
two to five pages long.
Here's a description of a bouquet of
chrysanthemums and madam swans chambers,
which segues into mention of a sunset
whose color is similar to the flowers,
which dog legs into a discussion of how
her former life as a kept woman with a
sideline in prostitution, nurture,
you know, debt as she's known to her,
numerous intimates,
a taste for a range of luxury goods
delivered to her door from exclusive
establishment spending
many around the small.
Here is a discussion of the
difference between the face.
A famous writers presents at a dinner
party and his interior life as laid bare
in his books and of the young narrators.
Astonishment at the contrast between
the two aspects of the men who's work as
long admired a contrast,
so marked that he thinks the party guest
must in fact be some other writer who
coincidentally bears the same name.
Here's a meditation on a musical phrase
that largest in swans memory after
repeating repeated hearings
here is times square.
I almost missed it and grossed in a
description of the acacia trees and the
public toilet on the shelves of these,
say where near where Marcel and she'll
bear to play hide and seek afterschool.
I pause mid sentence,
ride the human wave off the train
and come to rest on the platform.
Later when I resume reading,
I will cast around in the middle of a
two page paragraph to find my place.
Although in a 300 page stretch in which
Proust places under a microscope the
narrator's love for his playmate,
his pain when he decides to cut himself
off from the girl because she doesn't
love him back.
His brief conversations with her parents
when he visits her house and hours
carefully chosen so that the girl will
not be there and hearing about his visit
later will perhaps be intrigued and how
Odette accessorizes the Kimono she wears
when receiving guests.
Whether I resume exactly where I left
off inadvertently skip ahead or reread
half a page without realizing it right
away is if almost no consequence,
I come up the stairs and cross a wide
underground space on my way to board the
shuttle to grand central and
before I see them I hear them.
The warm ludic sounds
evoke an involuntary smile.
I follow the music to the top of the
stairs around the corner and behind a wide
pillar.
I stopped to soak up the feeling
that rolls off these musicians.
They're playing a washboard. Adults
Simmer, a fiddle attempt, marines,
symbols,
drums,
the Banjo and a basis though not all at
once as instrument to play a ratio is
about two two $1 bills and cds
spill out of an open guitar case.
The men are wearing odds and
ends reminiscent of other
worlds and times a Bolo
tie, a Bandana, a striped
railroad cap, a cowboy hat,
a stocking cap pulled down low over
dreadlocks with them is a woman who wears
her excess flesh like an urban stole
and passes out flyers to the sparse
audience, which is constantly
dispersing and replenishing itself.
When she runs out of flyers or audience,
she shimmies to the music in a manner
that appears deeply introspective.
The flyers and the handwritten sound
sign propped against the instrument case
announced that these are the ebony
hillbillies. The men are not young.
The calm they radiate is not a natural
fit with times square at rush hour,
but utterly at home in their music making.
They carry it off.
Their attitude captivates kindly never
rushed each one in gross and his own
playing and simultaneously adjusting to
his partners in numerous infinitesimal
ways. They are doing their thing
and doing it to perfection.
Soon I will hasten toward
the low cost mortgages,
the Cappuccino bar, the Arabic lessons,
the polities and the raspberries.
With whipped cream,
I'm always precisely 10 minutes late
and no one in the office ever seems to
notice, but for the moment I'm swept
up. Where do these men live? I wonder,
it's always the first
question in New York or asks,
do they ride the train
training from far Rockaway?
Maybe they've come in from
Jersey City on the path train.
Do they have day jobs benefits?
I doubt that anyone has ever gazed
admiring a miring Lee at their dental
insurance cards. They play drum, click,
scrape and saw one of them taps his toes,
another stamps,
his heel, a third does something
like singing but less melodious.
They do not look like the kind of
street musicians who interrupt.
They're playing to Bob their heads
and say thank you Ma'am to passers by
dropping coins, coins in their
case, no, they are not that kind.
I stand off to the side watching and
listening for as long as I can before
running to make my connection.
I head for the shuttle which goes
ceaselessly back and forth between times
square and grand central.
I have my pick of three trains on
parallel tracks, numbered one, two,
three and four.
They all go to the same place.
Someone wants to explain to
me why there's no track too,
but I forgotten the reason. There's
a track to elsewhere in the system,
but it Peters out before reaching
times square, something like that.
I clutch the little volume in one hand
preparing to open it and regain my place.
Mid sentence behind me.
The men.
Did they grow up together
somewhere in East Tennessee?
Did their group coalesced in a bar
in Brooklyn before Brooklyn was hip?
Are They Harlem born and bread
are still addict on the shuttle.
I'll read one more page,
maybe two.
If I recognize all the words about debt
and the ladies who come to her Wednesday
afternoons and discuss where they have
their dresses made or about a brothel
where the met him always urges Marcel to
try out a Jewish prostitute with messy
hair. She's better educated and a better
conversationalist than the others.
Since the mme and Marcel always dimmers.
No thank you.
Maybe next time I'll get off the
shuttle at grand central with the other
passengers and traverse the stations.
Cathedral like expense.
There are easier,
faster routes to work,
but a day that brings
with it a sense of awe.
Head tilted to take in that vast
space is a day not yet entirely lost.
I will admire the parolee faced clock
that anchors the center of the Grand Hall.
Go down a narrow marble
floored passage where vendors,
so grilled Hawaiian tuna,
peppercorn sausage cheeses that
virgin exquisitely on the foul,
mangoes, Bananas, foster cupcakes,
whatever they are. Tiramisu,
cake and other treats with names.
Fancy beyond recall wrapped in crinkly
paper or packed in bright tins and
dripping with snob appeal.
I will emerge from underground into the
city and the shadow of the green glass
building. I cannot hear the
music anymore. That's all. Folks,
I'll be happy to take questions about
anything I just read or said or anything
about the book.
Did you ever finish?
Sorry,
did I ever finish Cruz? I am
finishing Proust. I'm still finishing.
She's uh, I'm on volume four. Um,
I was reading volume one in oh seven,
I think.
So I put it down for years at a time and
the last time I put it down I decided I
should reread the parts
that I had read in French.
I should reread them in
English as a memory jog. Um,
so that took a year and
now I'm on volume for.
Seems like you learned French at
a later age and not, you know,
in school, correct me if I'm
wrong. How has that experience, um,
harder? Like what were your
resources, what were my sources?
Resources, sources. Well, I actually
had a very solid foundation in French.
I had taken it for five or six years
in middle school and high school.
And um,
I hadn't touched it or used
it in probably 20 years,
but it was all there. It was just like
opening a book that had been closed.
The grammar was all there. I just needed
to be, to learn how to comprehend,
spoken French and add vocabulary.
Um,
so I, I, as a freelancer,
I was able to take time to go to friends
and take French classes and mingle with
French people. And I had a mentor
who was already an interpreter,
the UN who was coaching
me through this process.
And she told me which newspapers to read,
what movies to go to,
what TV shows to watch,
uh, you know, go to plays,
find yourself a French speaking
boyfriend. She said to me, um,
so that was how I did it.
It took about six months.
MMM.
And it's important to note that since
I was working only from French into
English,
I didn't have to be able to speak
flawlessly or right flawlessly.
I only had to comprehend fro flawlessly.
And that's a passive skill that's much
easier to acquire than the act of skills
of speaking and writing
and other language. Um,
and although there's a widespread
perception that it's harder to learn a
language when you're an adult,
I don't think that's necessarily true,
especially if you've already
learned a foreign language,
then you have a lot of the conceptual
apparatus in place already and you just
need to add another layer.
MMM.
Because as another speaker in this
series, Noam Chomsky said, uh,
I'm not quoting verbatim, but the
idea is that grammar, the big,
the broad concepts of
grammar are the same,
generally the same from one language
to another. And when you master those,
you just have to add some
unique pieces for each language.
You intrigued me with your, um,
untranslatable statements about books.
I'm curious how you define that or
what makes a book on translatable?
What makes a book untranslatable?
Well, I can only say for myself,
okay,
what makes a book untranslatable?
Because other people then went on
and translated those books that I,
that I declined to.
I think as a translator,
you have to believe that everything is
translatable. Otherwise you're a fraud.
But as a person who knows more than
one language in more than one culture,
you know that it's not possible. So you
have to live with that contradiction
in my,
well literary translators like to say
that you can only translate those books
that you fall in love with.
And I didn't fall in love with any
of those books that I turned down.
So I guess that's the first condition
because literary translation is not
remunerative at all.
It's the worst paid form of translation.
Um,
I turned down books because there were
things about them that I felt I didn't
fully understand. Um, as it happens,
the books that I write about here
that I decided not to translate,
we're all oral history.
They did not have difficult
words or idioms in them,
but I felt that I would not be able to
capture the unique voice of the speakers.
Um,
one of them contained many,
many different speakers and I didn't know
how I was going to contrast them all.
They all felt different and I did a
sample of a few pages and I felt like
everything that I did was correct,
but there was something
about it that was not right.
Later I found out that the person who
had done the oral history in different
versions of the book,
she actually attributed the same
passages to different speakers.
So my concern, I was apparently
more conscientious than she was.
Um, but there are also words
that are untranslatable.
Um, I, somebody asked for this for an
interview recently, what's the word?
What's the word in Russian?
That's untranslatable and I answered,
there was a word that I encountered on
one of my first big stays in the Soviet
Union when it was still the Soviet Union.
The word is [inaudible].
The root is stolen, which means
table Za. The suffix means around.
And then the last part, yeah, just
indicates that it's an abstract nouns.
So this word literally means that
which goes on around a table.
Um,
but it means something like feast
plus banquet plus all the conversation
speechmaking toast,
drinking,
singing and the bonds
that are arising between,
among all the people around the table.
Um,
and all the work that went into putting
out that spread all in one word.
Um, in a culture where
feasting and gathering is very,
very important.
And it also is usually signifies kind of
a private family or friends event, not,
not an official. So how do you put
that all into one English word? Okay.
I want him to draw a parallel that,
that I'm a little embarrassed to
make as with many people here.
I write software for a living.
One of the things about software
is that it's never done.
You can always go back and
Polish it and improve it. And um,
your writing seems your, your style
of writing seems to be the same,
that however much effort you put into it,
however carefully you,
you craft it,
you can always go back and change it.
How do you know when you're done?
I know what I'm done because
the deadline has passed, but,
but how do you know when you're writing,
when you're done?
How do I know what I'm done?
Well,
there was a French poet who said, no work
of artists ever done, only abandoned.
MMM.
I do tend to procrastinate by spending
a great deal of time polishing.
That's a nice word for it. Uh, Oscar
Wilde said, I spent the day writing,
I spent the morning putting in a comma,
and then I spent the afternoon taking it
out. I don't know how I'm done. I mean,
for this book they were
revisioned deadlines,
but when I was writing the
pieces over the course of years,
nobody was waiting for them.
Uh,
I think that I was producing about 40,
35 or 40 publishable pages for many years,
a tiny amount.
And I guess when I just felt that I'd
spent enough time polishing and I wasn't
adding anything substantively
new, uh, then I would stop.
But they're never finished
until they're bound. But, um,
Raymond Carver used to get his books
from his publisher just published and he
would take out a pencil
and start correcting.
I'm tempted to do that sometimes.
Thank you very much.